Fox News confirms that FBI official
Andrew McCabe asked DOJ officials today
not to fire him before his retirement
takes effect on Sunday a pink slip could
cost him his pension benefits
McCabe oversaw the FBI investigation
into Hillary's email scandal but the
former Deputy Director announced his
resignation in January to avoid a likely
demotion the FBI reportedly recommended
firing McCabe after word leaked that the
do J's Inspector General concluded that
McCabe mislead investigators so let's
discuss this and other developments with
former FBI national spokesperson John
Anna Ellie and saw Eisenberg who is
deputy independent counsel under Ken
Starr all right so let's start with you
on this so McCabe has all this junk in
his past his wife you know getting the
you know help from from Hillary's friend
and in not revealing it of course and
then of course everybody's concerned
about the way he handled the email
investigation and now he's set to retire
on Sunday is it a little late to be
talking about firing him I mean
shouldn't if they were gonna fire him
why wait until like Thursday or Friday
right before he retires that just seems
bizarre to me it's it's bizarre and it's
a little unsettling and even a lot of my
friends who are in the Bureau and former
Bureau or a little upset with the timing
of it to come in two or three days for
the head of OPR within the bureau to
come in two or three days before his
retirement and put AG sessions in that
situation is a little bit weird and you
know Laura I am no fan of how mccabe has
handled these things keep in mind that
the only way an FBI agent is going to
really lose this pension is not through
general misconduct it is through
basically not telling the truth being
dishonest and that's what the what the
suppose it allegation is and of course
we haven't seen the OIG report we don't
know for sure what it is but there's
just something a little bit troubling
about the timing
the person who heads up OPR within the
FBI is not officer professional
intrusion yeah well I this not as a lot
of her rulings have been overturned you
know up at the next level in fact the
people that she's disciplined who who
then come back are known as boomerangs
in the Bureau book has a lot of her
rulings are overturned
yeah well it is it is again established
is it not John that we had a situation
where McCabe did not reveal the extent
of the help his wife received from a
very close friend of Hillary Clinton
when Andrew McCabe was leading the
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
email server of course Terry McAuliffe
connected PAC given that several hundred
thousand dollars to his wife's failed
bid for the state legislature that's all
true and all due respect to Sol I'm
going to disagree because the reality is
if they did something after he retires
there's no repercussions your pension is
not a guaranteed gift when you're an FBI
agent it's about living up to the
protocols and policies honesty and
integrity would you rather that he be
allowed to retire even though something
may have been done wrong and it was
determined by OPR yet he can benefit
agents are held accountable for their
behaviors and I think this speaks to
many things that happened when Mr McCabe
was working for director Comey Sarah
Huckabee today on the view said look
it's for this is for Jeff Sessions to
decide but she reenter
yeah but she written it was at a
briefing but she reiterated that this
was he was a bad actor in their view and
so she kind of gave the drive by but
he's a bad actor but this is up to Jeff
Sessions this is what that renowned
legal scholar sunny Hostin today said on
the view let's watch we've seen this war
on our intelligence community or this
war on the FBI I mean this man is a
career agent I don't know what he did or
did not do but I am troubled with this
constant attack on our intelligence
community because
[Applause]
assists of the dictators are made of
because the intelligence community never
gets anything wrong so they never make a
mistake and never get anything wrong
okay 911 it's a it's it's a ridiculous
comment but but again keep in mind you
know agents supervisors whoever they are
within the bureau they only really lose
their pension which is probably the best
pension in the whole US government for
the dishonesty that kind of dishonorable
conduct he would never lose his pension
because he did even if he really acted
was a bad actor in the email
investigation so if we just don't know
what's in the report so if it's
incredibly detailed and incredibly
damning and sessions has a chance to
look at it and make that decision in two
or three days that's one thing but
that's a that's a very big deal to come
in and present this to the Attorney
General with only two or three days for
him to look at it and and again I think
of this particular person the head of
OPR she didn't do the investigation she
just took the OIG s report and so I'm
troubled by the timing of it that's just
sessions may have seen a gotten a sneak
preview right John of what's in that IG
report i mean yeah i already knows
basically what's in it and so if it
comes out it's really bad i mccabe then
he sits on whoo I have a pension great
if that also looks odd it does and
Saul's right the reality is in the FBI
there's many things that can be forgiven
yet punished but lack of candor not
telling the truth is unforgivable agents
and support employees will be terminated
for that type of thing to happen and
there are no exceptions I think this is
a good message when there has been
leadership problems at times in the FBI
that no one can escape their
responsibilities to the job yeah well if
investigations look like they're at
their very core politicized that talk
about undermining the confidence of the
of the FBI and and Intel community
supposed to be calling balls and strikes
without concern for politics and that's
their my concern from the beginning yeah
really quick look
okay just don't forget that if he really
misled a federal investigation there's a
potential for a criminal referral
referral there so it's not like there
won't be anything yes well it's not like
there won't be any more options yeah we
gotcha
all right guys fantastic segment